so welcome everyone to our December PI
data annarbor event um so I just wanted
to start off by acknowledging our
sponsors so num focus who sponsors the
meetup TD Ameritrade who gives us this
lovely space
I might us for the food um and if you
have any comments questions or want to
tweet us the Twitter handle and our
email address are here at the bottom we
definitely do take suggestions and
feedback about the meetup so some
important points there are emergency
exits so there's an emergency exit over
here and then back out the way that you
came like I said feedback always preempt
myself and we are in a borrowed space
and it's a lovely space and we'd like to
keep using it so please treat it like it
the guest that you are and help clean up
after yourself so QA unless quick hold
questions until the end please phrase
your question in a form of a question
try to keep questions of 30 seconds or
less avoid long statements or monologues
and there will be time for open
discussion after Q&A I'm gonna read our
PI data Code of Conduct now PI data is
dedicated to providing a harassment free
meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
race religion or experience we do not
tolerate harassment of meeting
participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds and levels
of experience sexual language and
imagery is not appropriate for any of
our made up events be kind to others do
not insult or put down other attendees
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for pi data attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave the meet up
at the sole discretion of the meetup
organizers thank you for helping make
this
welcoming friendly event for all so
we're gonna do a quick icebreaker and
our icebreaker provided by our speaker
was snakes or lizards so please turn to
someone you do not know next to you
nearby and discuss interpret it as you
will
snakes or lizards we'll give you a
couple minutes all righty
I hope this has been an enlightening
experience for everyone and you've met
someone new and learn something new
about them so this month in data science
so there's a new podcast called learning
Bayesian statistics hosted by Alexandre
adore and Ora so take a look there's I
think four episodes or so take a listen
take a look at the website maybe and
then take a listen you have to look at
something anyway so there are probably
four episodes or so and I hear that it's
enlightening and interesting I have not
checked it out yet but I will
and then our next event in January will
be Eric mom on testing data science code
and that will be Wednesday January 15th
at 6 p.m. same place all right so does
anyone have any community announcements
so every month for those who are new
because there's an I know there's a
couple of you we invite folks in the
community to make announcements about
jobs or have jobs they're looking for
general community events and
announcements around in the data science
and PI data community real quick we've
got some books so by Matt Harrison and
Michael Kennedy you might have heard
Mike Kennedy on taught Python Python
bites Matt Harrison is also has a lot of
educational content related to Python as
well so thank you to them for sending
these books to us we're gonna do a quick
draw Ben and I have a each a number in
our brains right now so if you're our PI
charm release or the IDE books and in
usage of them if you're interested in in
one of these books please raise your
hand right now
we'll give it to her
thank you are there any other community
announcements since Sean was so exciting
and there was a game involved yes for
surveys of consumers I'm familiar with
our and also using so zipping here in
the front if anyone wants to come talk
to him afterwards please do well please
do anyway but any other community
announcements great so without further
ado Elizabeth Wix is a lecturer at the
School of Information Sciences at the
University of Illinois where she teaches
programming data curation and
information technology courses she has
previously been a data curation curation
manager and data curator there we go
she currently co organizes the
champaign-urbana python user group and
is serving on the carpentry Executive
Council for 2018 to 2020 welcome all
right I've got the Google slides
closed-captioning going which is not
like the best ever but it's free and
it's a button away so we've got that
going for it if you need thank you for
coming out I'm super excited to be here
the slides for this I've put up in
denote oh here's the DIY for that I also
just tweeted the link out as well so
this is gonna be a wild ride just to
reiterate a little bit about myself
because context I think makes everything
make more sense I teach programming to
grad students who are professional
students mostly library science did we
have any library science people in the
house Cricut love it so
okay fine carpentry is people half a
hand I like it I can get that okay yeah
um I've Co organized the Python user
group in champaign-urbana for like six
years now so I we have a weekly meet up
for just open work time so I see a lot
of beginners I work professionally with
a lot of beginners beginner independent
learners are sort of my life at this
point and so my research areas are
working with teaching people programming
who live sort of outside of stem so like
library science students generally come
from humanities degrees and so they have
not had any programming experience
before at all but also independent
learners to people who are job changers
or learning on the side things like that
people who are sort of outside of the
formal classroom I'm also really
interested in learning communities
communication and information resources
especially about programming communities
as well so how do we find information to
answer our questions how do we get the
job done
I believe programming is a very
information centric practice first
information secondary linguistic third
humanities sort of so that's my very
unique take on things I'm also really
interested in from in investigating
effective and sustainable data
management and curation practices for
research programmers as well because
it's hard
documentation is hard right so how can
we do it what's the most minimal thing
you can do that would be the most
effective because that's frankly what we
got let's figure out what it is and
let's start from that instead of
starting from the beautiful world okay
so because the beautiful world never
gonna happen I'm trained as librarian
social scientists and information
professional I have incredibly strong
feelings about information resources so
some of that is gonna come out today so
briefly what is information sciences I
was asked to explain this I wish at some
point in my life I could talk more just
about my work and less about what my
domain means but it's okay
here for it okay so from the I schools
mission statement I forgot to turn on my
timer for what's going on so I've
actually got yelled at so from the I
schools mission statement we were
focused on understanding the use of
information in science culture society
commerce and diverse activities of our
daily life
so we are all over the place but sort of
really about how do people get things
done we talked about this sort of the
triangle of information technology and
people and these are the nodes that we
really try to keep in focus in all of
our research you cannot forget about any
of them they needs to be equal partners
in how you're investigating the world so
what this comes down to is I cannot give
Tech Talk without a huge portion talking
about so the human cost of screwing
things up right we talk not about how to
develop an algorithm but how people are
impacted by algorithms for example we're
gonna take care of some of that business
now we're gonna revisit this a little
bit later this is gonna be less of a
technical talk like there's plenty of
those there's all kinds of you things on
YouTube we're gonna be technical but
don't fret like you don't there will be
some code but you will not need to
understand the code sort of grok what
I'm after
we cannot inspect technical problems and
code and things around that within a
vacuum that ignores the humanity and the
community a context around those
problems those are both vital
communities humans make code code or
presents humans this should not be a
Forgotten element of our work code is
not neutral and any problem or solution
investigated around those lines needs to
include the community elements that have
created communities could make problems
communities solve problems because
communities are humans humans are the
actors a question okay so I also want to
make a strong point of order I am going
to be critical of some open source
projects and documentation in this talk
but I want to strongly acknowledge I am
NOT being critical of the people the
intention or the effort behind those
projects it is hard it is hard work
maintain errs put in a lot of effort
often most of the time uncompensated
efforts towards making these things work
I will reiterate what PyCon has been
doing he notes about for several years
if your company uses open source
products your company had better start
please
really donating to those open source
projects to sustain them or donate
and/or donating your time to support
them it is hard important work I would I
am grateful to work for the work that
they put in
and I want us all to work together to
make it better okay so with that we are
a community of practice it is beautiful
it is wonderful we were a community of
human beings also around the globe
Python is huge all over the place so we
are prosol providers of situated
learning within our communities and that
was a sort of a really important point
of a community of practice who are my
beginners in the house you're sort of
beginning to pipe on getting going with
things welcome you're all wonderful and
I'm so happy that you're here you're
here to learn and we also need to learn
from you but what you need and how it
can better help things so doing
activities like being a mentor being a
supervisor a team lead a helpful
colleague providing formal and informal
instruction writing tutorials to be
reviewing books attending things like
this giving talks etc this is all part
of situated learning we learn from each
other across all levels this is what
makes us a community of practice we are
making a practice together it's
important so together we learn and teach
and share our values and provide these
rubrics for identity like who here like
sort of identifies as like I am a Python
person or pythonista or whatever word
makes sense okay a couple of hands will
get your hands up don't worry about that
the actions and practices that we
showcase like for example reading the
code of conduct as at the very top of
the talk showcases what's normal and
acceptable like these are the boundaries
and rules of our community and we police
them internally and we police them by
sort of this give-and-take of identity
like oh you cannot be a Python person
anymore if you violate these tenets of
our community um
likewise if we erase the representation
and work of someone from a community
we're kind of erasing their identity and
that's really hurtful so we need to be
watchful for these things and I know I
know but Wix we're here to talk about
data right and five on maybe at some
point I know we're get there the problem
of not having numbers in your data is
stood are twofold um one your data
doesn't often conform to the
expectations of tutorials and things and
it's coming in from wild places which is
I think wonderful I love those
challenges but it just means that the
ramped up to being able to run like a
bar chart on something it was really
hard okay a lot of the tutorials that we
publish are really problematic for
people who are not coming in with
spreadsheets okay so I want to unpack in
this talk what does this cost us and
cause in our community many will think
these tried like that like I got folder
of data I got maybe some spreadsheets I
got some stuff I've got a little bit of
Python skills okay let's hit this you
google some things make bar chart in
Python something like that
you managed to get through all of the
environment packaging stuff and you're
like great I can cool I'm importing
pandas life should be good from here
right and then they hit a bunch of
errors and they have half an hour of
errors and what are you supposed to do
at that point if you don't have a
community around you
or you don't see yourself or your
workflow and those documentation so some
people are gonna think python is just
not for me and they bail right at every
point in the road you have a choice you
have a fork you can either bail or you
can dig deeper right um now for some
people this might be so some people also
take this a little bit further and say
not only is python not for me but
programming is not for me sometimes this
is a fine call for that moment in time
and I have counseled people out of
learning Python because another tool is
going to provide the better value add
for their time at that point right it
happens right so the cost of learning
how to code might not meet the value of
being able to code at that point in that
person's life and it's important to
acknowledge but for a lot of other
people this is a false negative when
we've lost some unvalued
a valuable voice to our community and
the people that we have lost along the
way should keep us up at night we should
be deeply concerned about the people we
lose so how have you gotten here um got
really heavy for the fast I know
right right breathe okay we're gonna be
action items at the end we ready from
action eyes at 7:00 p.m.
let's talk about some of the data that I
interact with sort of what sort of data
does library science at we are super
interdisciplinary as you saw from that
mission statement or heard from the
mission statement we have a lot of
different coverage areas so imagine
things like huge bibliographic databases
like the entire library catalog like not
a not metadata just about one book but
about the entire catalog that's a
dataset that we might work with um what
I'm going to talk about here represents
like maybe 10% of what we actually do
with 10% being completely made up but to
give you an idea that it's a tiny slice
of what we actually talked about so some
people that I work with work with the
entire corpus of PubMed Central some
people work with just the bibliographic
entry some people work with the entire
text of those papers the hot horse
research center H TRC has metadata on
sixteen point seven million volumes or
books so to everything in google books
they've scanned exists in this big old
digital library and so they've got not
just data on the the volume itself but
about each single page in that book so H
page is scanned and OCR so they've got
metadata about that page and about the
words and precomputed analytics about it
about Twix at this point 20 million
things so we have a lot of really big
stuff we do have like actual books and
other physical objects that we preserve
and take care of this also means that we
have pest data and location and climate
data because you've got physical objects
you've gotta like make sure they're not
getting eaten by crickets for example or
like undergrads leaving crumbs there's a
reason we don't ask you who is mean to
not eat food in library um we work a lot
with digital humanities information
modeling provenance prospective and
retrospective as well reproducibility
just like a lot of metadata happening cv
a snapshot of just how like wild my
world is and I love it um just inside
the building or my office is we've got
the Center for children's books which
has a huge non circulating collection of
children's books they do outreach and
training and reviews and newsletters the
Center for informatics research and
science and scholarship which is just a
like a lot of social science or on data
and reproducibility things
and data curation and then the hot toys
research center that I mentioned before
so it's a wonderful broad landscape but
I was trying to think for this talk like
how to explain like what is iconically
different about library science
information science data it's often top
talking about physical objects but less
of the physicality of that object but in
there like we talk about it we have
those measurements it's more than all
it's also more than just the content in
the context it's sort of everything
meshed in together it is insufficient to
measure just the physical object so like
here's my prop here's my planner right
does the physical measurements of this
planner talk to its existence or present
it as an object yes if I wanted to put
it on a shelf I would need to know the
dimensions of it but it's about what's
inside right any zones just about the
content right it's also about how that
content is presented and organized and
used so it's insufficient just to
measure the count the ID object it's
also insufficient just to transcribe the
content of it right it's sort of hitting
this delightful balance where how can
you transform this physical object and
semantic content into something that's
computationally powerful which means you
have to balance this readability and
authentic representation where you like
you open up the file and you're like
that's a book got it
duck typing still working right but
you've made it into something that's
computationally powerful and I think
that's what a lot of our data speaks to
so some examples are the data files that
I work with like just a lot of XML HTML
for web scripting as well across a lot
of different schemas and sometimes XML
files with multiple schemas at play so
that's fine metadata about objects and
collections looking across the corpus
itself the whole corpus is the data set
we process a lot of free text including
subject heading controlled and
uncontrolled and theoretically
controlled vocabularies databases API is
a lot of giant overly formatted Excel
things so many PDFs you have no idea and
just as a snapshot we're going to look
at sort of three examples as well
this is a project that I worked on at
the library when I was there we were
trying to create this internal metadata
schema to hold some data and part of
that schema was gonna get punted out to
the public into a metadata store and we
wanted to make sure that we were sort of
in compliance not just with the
documentation but with how the broader
community was using the schema cuz the
documentation was a little bit like not
sure what you're asking me to do there
so how is how are other people doing
this right so this is an example of only
the records and I was interested
specifically in just this one element
that's happening in here you don't
actually need to read it just know then
it's a small part of what's going on um
so I hid their metadata store and got
about 50,000 payload files and those
unpacked into about 50 like three
million XML files and so I sort of
gathered what I could that made sense
out of here as well but I was just kind
of profiling how is this element and
attribute being used what are the who
how many people are using it and who's
putting it in so this is actually an
element necessary to hook a data set to
the relevant paper before if anyone's
into reproducibility sort of this is
really important for a citation that
works and things what I ended up
gathering was a lot of text data and
some dates like the most numerical thing
I had was like some dates happening in
there so what do these look like to you
is VN right ah but hey we've got numbers
there in a column this looks like
computationally promising right how do
you think these are connected so they
iced me n so they got to be like books
of some form but can you tell who know
is right unless you have unless you're
an iOS PN parser like you're not gonna
know these are actually books that were
censored from a prison so we had the
education justice project is part of the
Danville Correctional Center in Illinois
and they are a college program that
lives inside of the prison to let people
take courses while they're serving their
time and that program had a library of
about 4,000 books and then all of a
sudden one day 202
got pulled
explanation no warning just disappeared
and went into like someone's trunk or
something it's been a couple years and
we still don't really know why they were
selected or what the reason was for
pulling them we're getting some a lot of
scattered things these are the ISP ends
of the books that were pulled okay
my colleague dr. Emily Knox is an expert
in book censorship in book banning and
she's investigating this and I offered
to do some data crunching for her this
all started as a big PDF of just like
titles and authors and then it turned
into this column of is beans and then of
course that turned into XML files so
here is a little snapshot of that I
harvested the library of congress
catalog record for all of these books
and extracting subject tags sort of
these little chunks in here again
there's it's just text text with a
little bit of hierarchy in structure but
just text I also want to talk about
about finding ants so long shot has
anyone done research in an archives yay
hand alright so I adore finding aids I
don't do our Chi for research or
research in an archives but I adore
finding aids because they are by humans
for humans solely but they're so
computational in structure I love them
what they are is so when an archives
gets a collection they have to process
it but like the stuff that can be in
noise collections is like wild you can
have like nested grocery bags of post-it
notes and like receipts right could be
one of them and so you're like how do I
represent this in a data mile model how
do I represent a bagful of CVS receipts
with like a book scrawled on the back
right like that's the kind of stuff that
they get and they have to like preserve
it and keep track of it people also need
to visit and then say like so everything
is sort of cataloged into a box and so
bee hive here is sort of the box number
these are letters to dude and here's
sort of information about the letters
letters those inside of folders and the
folders live inside of boxes we're gonna
dig into this a little bit more it's
just text location names IDs in a lot of
PDFs
yeah hopefully we can see a common theme
and problem here there's no numbers
happening there's not even like a decent
spreadsheet happening so what happens
when you're like I've got some
computationally cool data and I've got
some Python skills and I see this
awesome gallery of cool things I can do
in Seabourn okay and I'm like okay I've
got cool stuff over here I can do some
fiddly bits and for here let's make some
cool visualizations happen well this is
my choice right now I wasn't expecting
it to be a hundred percent because
that's not what visualizations are for
it's a reason why we have so many I
think we can agree though that this is
like not a lot that I could do when I
just have text data in here
so also this was not a scientific review
so like don't at me that like no you
could actually do a violin plot with
that so like simmer down
but like plus or minus a few it's still
not a ton I could do let's also look at
some of the documentation around these
things so this is we have plotly up here
Seabourn and this is from the pandas
documentation for matplotlib in red
we've got sort of some beautifully
perfect data frame or tabular structure
and on in like this sort of the magenta
over here we've got like where are the
numbers at in here now also this one
just says tips who knows what they mean
by the tips data there's for the record
of the video if there's no hands one
hand a couple okay there's your hands
thank you yes wait not a thought if
people are like oh I definitely know the
tips data set I also know exactly how
its structured and the data model
expectations and how its formatted for
it oh so there's no link
it's the tips data set for like what is
that data I don't even know I have
Google it anyhow um also this is a row
this is not even a column there's just a
lot happening in here so these tutorials
presume that data is coming in in a well
formatted tabular file and is composed
mostly of numerical data remember my
data got XML and PDFs and
sketchy spreadsheets okay a novice
coming into these things so like a lot
of us would know because we were a lot
of us are experienced in analytics
across a lot of different platforms
they're like I think you really just
have to like get all those things into a
spreadsheet that looks fine like they're
sort of that intuitive nature once you
it's not really intuitive its intuitive
because that's been forced on us like
from a novice perspective why is it that
we have to get everything into a CSV
file like to me
XML what I have is perfectly well
structured perfectly well formatted why
can't I point Python to my XML file I
make a bar chart off of that right again
cuz the novice doesn't hasn't
experienced these things yet
and so we're not making explicit that we
expect data to be in a certain form okay
we're not making explicit that we expect
the categorical column to exist we're
not making explicit that we expect like
one like if you familiar with the tiny
verse sort of like the Thai deep data
format we're not making that explicit in
this documentation it's what Seabourn
wants but like in the last page of their
documentation actually says it this is
after someone's probably desperately
copy and pasted who is like tried to
make a cool tool work and you sat
through with tutorials and you just
literally copy and pasted to try and
make any of it work on some data that
you had right how many of you were
successful for the record there's fewer
hands right is the same thing so some of
you bailed
did anyone bail from that tool yeah yeah
because it's hard especially when you
don't have colleague next to you glowing
light and you can hear like what even is
this thing right so there's a problem
here right and again I'm not criticising
the authors of this I'm not criticising
the tools it is hard it is hard work and
I'm pointing out a thing we can improve
on okay I also want to acknowledge like
okay so most of the tutorials are
teaching out the tools themselves which
leaves ink and data focusing on the
shortest example possible and for many
of us that's not a bad thing because the
questions we're coming at it with
our reference questions like is it type
or kind when I do dot plot I always get
it wrong um so like that is an example
of a reference question like I already
have some data I already know to use dot
plot and I know I can specify what type
of plot I want I just can't remember
what attribute to use for it um but it's
often not acknowledging the data also
needs to be transformed into a specific
shape so there's two pieces of that that
it needs to be transformed and to into a
specific type of format okay who's had
to fight with melting data into just the
right weird thing yeah like that's
totally normal okay
do you remember it all the first time
you encountered that and you had to
realize like oh it wants that kind of
column okay
these tutorials aren't making this
explicit I'm sure one of them does don't
at me at that one either um so if you're
producing tutorials with this voice of
like but you should already know how to
do this what sort of research are we
leaving on the table who are we leaving
out now scope is important but remember
there's a lot of different reasons if
someone's going to use that tutorial
not uh not everyone using these
tutorials that I highlighted earlier are
going to be at Python experts who are
like I've already got a data frame
happening in my life it's great it's a
great data frame I just need you to plot
it right like that's not people's lives
not everyone is gonna think like oh
clearly I need to transform these XML
files into a well formatted CSV with
this specific kind of columns like
that's just not something as a novice
naturally thinks they're like super
focused on their data I need to make a
bar chart I can like draw it for you
please Python do this thing now like
they're not thinking through all of
these steps that they haven't done them
before now why do I care about this so
much I'm gonna read some non profit
words for you let's take a visit to the
Python Software Foundation mission
statement okay the mission of the Python
Software Foundation is to promote
protect and advance the Python
programming language pretty clear right
and to support and facilitate the growth
of a diverse and international community
of Python programmers okay diversity is
important to us
also the num fishin statement who is a
sponsor of Pi data envisions an
inclusive scientific and research
community okay this goes for our human
bodies and exist you man existence as
well as our data okay
inclusion and diversity is a core tenant
of our communities no matter which
community you're coming from okay now
here's gonna series it questions okay do
you believe that Python as a language is
something different and uniquely
important in the programming world
that's arguable maybe okay do you
believe in the power of open source yeah
I got fists right there yeah open source
do you want as many people as you need
it to be able to use Python in their
work like we're here at a Python meetups
Oh like clearly we kind of care about
that right
do you believe is Python that Python is
a uniquely valuable language within the
data universe it does some uniquely cool
things
so with this context what if I told you
that we're losing people that we're
missing out on entire populations of
people okay that's why this is important
because the core tenants of our
community dictate that we should care so
I'm here to help you want to care and
later to give you some action items
about how you can incorporate caring
about this okay I'm not saying we did
this on purpose it is natural it happens
it is common to do analytics with
numbers the stats presumes numbers like
that's fine that's a thing um
it's common to have spreadsheets and
CSVs and databases it's common to have
sort of rectangles of data happening in
your life for analytics it is common to
do some levels of transformation to that
data for your analytics all these things
are super common there is nothing wrong
with having that as a focus of your
documentation and your tutorials and
your tools okay but this is all we can
and data in the world to be were lost
okay um and these are not even edge
cases that we're dealing with these are
like entire academic fields that are
like my data will never look like that
unless I just do a lot of things or I
have a GA you can just do a lot of
things that I won't understand
not that I even want to publish on
something I don't understand right so
remember the implications that I
mentioned earlier there we lose people
who bail when I can't make the things
work when your data isn't part of the
majority we should have a question he's
really not part of the majority right
there's a lot of different data out
there you have to search for harder you
have to work longer you have to work and
rely more on unhealthy grit and dumb
luck okay it should not require that a
researcher has an unhealthy level of
stubbornness and grit to be able to use
open source tools right if that is an
expectation that we're saying to survive
this you have to like have an unhealthy
inability to quit like I don't think
that's good for us as a community right
so where are the gaps there's this gap
of acknowledgement that this stuff has
to happen that this kind of data even
exists on that ETL is a primary activity
in our pipelines there's also a gap in
how we provide advice and suggestions so
let's go back to the library world
remember I'm a trained librarian right
but as also ullscreen also trained in
data science we have a Waco reference
interviews just sort of a very
structured framework for like you who
has ever gone to a reference desk in a
library middle school included okay okay
you asked a question and someone
answered it you may have an undergrad
that's fine but like librarians are
trained to be able to field those kinds
of questions there's a certain framework
of like I hear you've asked me this do
you maybe mean this kind of question and
then they give you
tailored customed advice okay who here
has asked a question of a colleague and
20 websites later you're like I'm gonna
be done with this Thanks
and like out right um sometimes we
forget to shut up because we're so
excited about things and that's natural
but sometimes you got a chill right so
let's take this challenge I come up to
you and maybe I a person and a tech
meetup and I'm like I've got a bunch of
like categorical data that's really cool
I really want to make a bar chart out of
it what do you think I should do thank
for a moment how you would react to that
question I hope positively because we're
a wonderful inclusive community so let's
start with that but like what's the
first thing you would a soar first thing
you would suggest just think about that
for a second okay who's the bought of a
tool like Oh C bar make school bar
charts who thought of a tool something
like that um who thought like I think
maybe Excel might actually be just fine
for this which might actually be the
right answer any one part of Excel
that's fine yeah um did anyone think of
asking me how my data was structured
yeah you get it
yeah if we don't open with this if we
don't talk about these things if you
take them out of the conversation if you
take the data for transformations out of
the conversation then you focus solely
on tool use like I've seen this a lot of
they're like oh I want to do some data
visualization and they're like C bar
take a lie or something like that like
fine those are fine tools but not that's
like the endpoint of the conversation
that shouldn't be the majority of the
conversation unless I was like with GD
visualization tool are you willing to
fist fight about um and so we are
excluding people from the conversation
who don't have data that cleanly fits
for those tools when we don't talk about
it okay
users still have responsibilities here
you still have to like learn what a bar
chart is that's not open sources
responsibility okay but presuming that
an user magically knows to do all of
those transformative actions will cause
people to bail and we shouldn't have
people who were bailing because they
can't make the doodads work right if it
doesn't make sense for their science
that's fine but if they can't make the
examples work and that's why they're
bailing we've done a bad thing we've got
a problem
okay that we need to solve okay so who
here is responsible for interviewing
early career data science people okay
who here is encountered a student who
like doesn't quite get that what I call
life after Kaggle is that they think the
data science workflow is I download data
from Kaggle and I make cool models off
of it yeah yeah and you're like ooh
that's not life though that's like
Friday afternoon right Monday through
Thursday is like actually trying to find
where the data lives Friday morning is
maybe documenting it and doing a
performance review and going to the
doctor and then Friday afternoon I can
actually build my models right if we are
not acknowledging this transformative
action of data within our workflows
we're going to be producing people who
don't think that that's a thing and then
they're going to be surprised because
it's totally a thing if we do this then
we're failing at providing appropriate
situated learning with our people okay
so what do you do what do you do with
non numerical data you mostly really
just count things a lot in a lot of
different ways it's kind of what we got
to be the example I rewrote a sequel
lesson from software carpentry for
actually use with a finding aid with
that pedigree data set um a lot had to
get stripped out like the entire chunk
about calculating new values because
like recalculating Celsius into
Fahrenheit not a relevant activity for
this sort of data we had to take out a
fair bit of aggregation as well so like
what says sum total of box numbers
technically I can calculate that but
it's complete nonsense min and Max
actually still useful to sort of see the
range of values in here but mostly we
just do count and group by for stuff you
can do some visualization but it's
really limited to sort of EDA like
activities which is exploratory data
analysis so don't actually read the 1977
book for EDA I love that people always
quote it but no one's happy to read the
book it's beautiful it's a fun book it's
there a lot of essays but how did by
graph paper it's beautiful so let's look
back at this fine
right so this is a letter so Thomas
Pettigrew he did a lot of like
Egyptology things it's held in Yale
University there's four point five nine
linear feet 13 boxes and a total of 21
boxes in the collection we've got our
spreadsheets it's got numbers in columns
right this looks promising so let's dig
in okay box numbers are numbers and
folder numbers also numbers the date
column it's kind of a lot happening in
that date column so maybe that's
something for a later day we've got some
extra lines happening like in here where
it's descriptive about this letter
happening again it's for people not not
for computers um
the headers though easily handle so
let's read this into pandas so here
importing pandas we're gonna read excel
and then say skip those first three rows
we're gonna use this drop na to get rid
of those sort of empty empty rows that
we don't care about and then we're gonna
take a look and here we go this is
plausible right I've got like columns
and there's number is happening so like
I'm well on my way to making a bar chart
right um we've got numbers over here
that's clearly a number I like it
and then here we've got numbers if
you're for those far away we have 1.0
and then one to a panda's user you
probably know what's going on that this
got red in numerically and this got red
in as an object because something wonky
is happening right but would a novice
pick that up probably not probably less
so and let's try some of this
documentation so this is the pandas
documentation on how to make a bar chart
kind equals plot on the row this is a
lot happening in this tutorial it's not
really explained I get why it's just
sort of wild um so I'm gonna call dot
plot on one of my columns and I get this
which looks like data like there's
something happening so that's cool but
does it look like what I wanted doesn't
sync right okay
this focus on the smallest example it
loses the context of what this data
frame is his this data frame is like
cumulative sums and these numbers are
literally in there already happening and
so they haven't had to do any
transformative actions because they're
trying to make the smallest possible
example to work and if you were just
like which attribute name do I use like
yeah that's this would healthy helpful
implicitly they wanted me to do a group
by to count and if we do all of this
nonsense we can perform that action of
count how many folders or how many lines
there are for each box number in here
okay this is not trivial code for a
novice your few pandas all day long this
is probably fine for you okay but this
is not trivial code to a novice or
intermediate person okay um
index position is actually really
interestingly valuable in these data
sets because the structure itself going
for the top down is actually informative
because you theoretically have like all
of box one then all of box two and all
of box three and you're like I think
that's true but there's like 600 rows in
here and I'm not gonna look through all
of those so you can see it's sort of
stepping up which is actually pretty
informative you have done here the index
position and here sort of the numbers
that it's seeing and so you can see by
this little step that yes it must be
working in order and you're like cool
I've made some things that look like
images and I'm feeling good and
confident and then you try to go to the
folder number and no numeric data to
plot and your luck runs out
it's because what has happened here is
the full there's a couple of the letters
that are live in multiple folders and so
there's a couple of instances in that
folder column where it's like 542
through 552 something I see if a couple
range isn't here and so you have a
choice like how do I even data model
this there's a bunch of different
choices for that at sort of the most
minimal I can just delete them and then
plot the rest and sort of see what's
going on you can sort of see these
really tight you could totally no one
else can except for
well these these little tiny blips here
in here but otherwise it's nicely linear
which tells me that against against the
index position that the folder numbers
are actually running incrementally okay
let's move on to another example so you
have a pile of books in front of you can
you tell what they're about and how
they're connected okay can you do this
computationally at scale because that's
hard so where can we get a credible
report about topics in a book who is
thinking I'm gonna do some topic
modeling on descriptions from Amazon or
like I'm gonna go to Goodreads and find
some tags in here if only there was a
massive freely accessible data source
the authoritative information about
books and an API that didn't require a
key enter Library of Congress has the
business right now subject headings
across the world and all schemas are
difficult all techsan amis at some point
in their lives have been racist do not
try to come up with your own taxonomy
because you're gonna have super problems
do you know that librarians are trained
on how to make taxonomy z' and we still
mess up right so taxonomy czar hard
subject headings have historically been
difficult but when it comes to race
issues but they're better than previous
they've been improved at least there is
so they're not perfect but they are
human curated and easily obtainable okay
so let's zoom in on a bit of this XML
from one of these things that I gathered
so these are a bunch of three separate
subjects elements in here and it's the
topic nodes that I want inside the
subject elements this is the actual text
which of the subject headings for these
books overlays this one book in
particular um goal make numbers out of
this right
can't make bar chart without numbers but
what are we measuring so like there's
letters here do I care about the estus
do I care about the letter Ness
the characters of this is that my unit
of analysis no I don't really care
to make about the words are the words my
unit of analysis maybe are the tags my
unit of analysis probably also but also
there can be zero to many of these
subject tags for one book and also
internally there can be a hierarchy of
primary and secondary subject tag inside
of one of them so it's not a clean
process so with these things to like
grab the first step is at least like I
don't know what I'm going to do with
these words but I should like extract
them is probably the plausible first
step enter bag of words so what do you
do when you have a whole heap of words
and you're like I guess I need numbers
out of these things somehow bag of words
I really what's come in handy here we
will talk a little bit about what bag of
words is when we sort of get to that
point in the workflow so a lot of non
numerical data starts off not intended
to be data I think that's beautiful and
I think that's where data science really
needs to go when we're generating
insights out of things we never thought
could give us data I love the sort of
trying to extract data out of things
that are not data um so just to recap
this started off as a PDF of book titles
and authors it became a spreadsheet that
a GA transcribed and then manually
looked up ISBNs for I grabbed that
column of I or spins hit the Library of
Congress at the 202 items 156 had an
ISBN that makes sense because some of
these were like websites that were
printed off because prisoners can't have
like all the internet access that they
just need a lot of paper because that's
controllable and so 156 both had an ISBN
and a Library of Congress records we
ended up with 156 XML files um then from
that I created this matrix this bag of
words after extracting two things from
XML so how do we calculate a bag of
words first you have to like gain access
to the text at question in this case I
used XPath and here just grabbing the
the topic nodes and then extracting the
text out of them this is part of L XML
if you want to nerd out about XPath
please talk to me afterwards I love it
you have to also somehow then detect the
vocabulary from that text so like gain
access to the text and then pluck apart
the vocabulary from its from the entire
corpus so like of all the words that I
see here here all the unique words count
how many of those words appear inside of
each document and then slam all that
business into a data structure of your
choice a lot of people do a two
dimensional list I use list of
dictionaries in this case whatever
floats your boat it's got to end up as a
data frame at some point if you want to
do cool things with it so bag of words
is fun because once you have this
there's a variety of other calculations
you can do on the corpus a lot of them
are used for feature detection and data
mining and text mining applications like
what this is like if you've heard of
tf-idf but not really known what and why
the sort of this is why like trying to
detect powerful words that for
classification purposes um for us though
we just really want to see what's going
on we're sort of still solidly in that
EDA stage we're like what are these
books about clearly there's some racist
things happening just like reading the
first page of this PDF but like 156
books there could be other things
happening um so this is an example
record this is the title and this is the
unique key actually have no idea where
this neat key came from it was just in
the spreadsheet and unique then these
four things I always keep the raw
context the original unprocessed data
just to like habit I had the benefit of
only having 156 books so like I could
keep all the business that I wanted and
these are the unique words present
across all of the subject headings I
stemmed the words which sort of takes
off it actually didn't really take off
anything inside of here but it would
have taken off pluralization and things
like that and it just just does is
reduce the total number of unique words
which reduces the dimensionality and the
sort of a cluttery business that happens
and then I came up with the unique
values of the stemmed words in here and
this just gives me like four separate
data sets to kind of play with to
utilize to see which one fits the best
and here we finally have hey howdy look
at those numbers yay
I have numbers finely right so of 156
books there were 353 unique subject
headings across them so slammed all that
business into a data frame using sort of
up here we have like a multi index with
that unique ID because some of the
titles were actually repeated this is
the unique ID and then the title over
here we have the subject heading and
then here we have the counts so for
example in this book called research
matters
it had one tat once I was heading of
academic writing in here and this of
course continues on 400 more right um
and then because I had my wonderful data
frame full of beautiful numbers then
Seabourn was gonna be happy with me hey
you got number so here is a heat map I
wanted to make a heat map just to sort
of see the overall spread of these tags
and I wanted to sort it so it wasn't
just sort of like chaos all over the
place I wanted to sort from the top down
the most common subject headings and
tags this heat map is actually using the
stemmed values of the words and not the
subject headings themselves because it
was really long um pretty like simple
ish to do if you know some data frame
jamming some the total numbers across
each row of subject heading into a total
column sort the data frame by the total
column then digit so it doesn't like
mess up my beautiful heat map and boom
here we have a heat map for things um so
there was a lot of work like
individually like this definitely took
about 12 hours probably for this student
to let go organize this spreadsheet it
took me two hours just to find a library
of congress API that i could actually
make work right with ISBNs because that
was all i had for the books and then it
took about another hour or two to like
extract all the business out of the xml
files and like I'm really good at things
so when I calculate how much work load
it is for a novice student I usually
multiply my time by ten so they give and
take me one hour
to do this it would probably take a
novice at minimum ten hours a lot about
being investigation time um keep that
multiplier in your head if you're an
expert and you're dealing with novices
because it really changes the scale of
how you think about time spans for
things
uh yeah yeah numbers yeah heat map so
let's review what had to happen it took
a lot of transformations just to get
literally any cut like the number one it
took a lot of work just to get to one in
there there's great documentation on how
to generate a bag of words but that
presumed that ia knew I should use a bag
of words model to calculate these things
and be had full access to the vocabulary
I questioned a lot of those tutorials
are just like here's a canned data file
of text or just gonna make up some fake
sentences in there by hand which is not
real because you have to somehow read it
in and make the business happen once we
had to once we calculate the vocabulary
we had to force it into this rectangular
shape into a model that I knew Seaborn
wanted I knew see but we wanted a data
frame I needed to get a data frame of
numbers happening right so the fact that
I have to conform my data to the tools
model is one of those tacit things we're
used to dealing with but from a novice
perspective why can't the tool conform
to my data model right both are equally
plausible um we're doing a disservice to
newcomers when we hide the
transformations required to like make
the business happen in here now this
doesn't mean you have to teach them but
you should acknowledge that it has it
should happen like literally one
sentence ensure you load your data and
it looks like I don't know fake up a
markdown table or something in there
like you need 20 words to make this
acknowledgement happened that would give
people are probably like oh I do need to
get my data transform don't mean go take
care of that now before then just change
this file name from your tutorial and
desperately try to make it work here's
your close to action bring it home
understand the point of reference versus
instruction in here reference for
example is oh what's that order of argue
again and wait is this type or kind for
dot plots this is where you're extremely
pay the examples come into play and are
really valuable because like as an
expert I'm just referencing what
structure does this are does this
pattern need to have instruction is
different instruction involves
paragraphs early sentences a few
sentences would be frankly wonderful to
have so no you don't have to tell them
what a bar chart is they should figure
that out on their own that's fine that
you should explain what the data is
you're bringing in explain what tips is
and provide a link so I can see what's
the structure of tips
I can't assess whether or not I can do
that visualization unless I can see what
data it is that you're working with okay
random numbers are not universal data in
there if it's normal to aggregate the
data before performing the analysis the
visualization and the tool or whatever
going on just say it
like bt-dubs you should do a group by
now and then come back at me with
something that looks like X write one
sentence really we really save a lot of
people time and heartache show it
happening so it's an honest authentic
use case okay don't just make a fake
data frame that already has it
aggregations right because then the user
thinks like I thought when I was first
learning are all I need to like run my
analysis and then manually type in the
aggregation data frame myself and then
visualize that was that effective for my
workflow very bad but I didn't know any
better and I was desperate just to get
anything done so um acknowledgement is
important so people know there's that
extra step because so they can go seek
out help because if you say you need to
aggregate your business here they're
like oh I don't know how to aggregate
well all the sudden they have a well
formed query it's coming to a tech
meetup and say I'm not sure how to
aggregate data in pandas that's a really
well formed query right versus I can't
make a bar chart happen help me please
right which one would you prefer
yeah recognize also that users with text
data have unique data preparation needs
and differing data structures
clear about your model expectations this
goes for internal documentation too like
if you're like I'm expecting this this
tool expects your data to look like blah
make a fake version of it or something
you can do in a new markdown table right
um that's kind of what I have just sort
of be awesome to each other and admit
that you have to do more than just the
smallest example possible in your
tutorials okay I have no idea what time
it is cool that's what I have Hey
and back yeah so there was a question
about the results of my analysis of
subject headings which is super
preliminary and actively current work
that we're gonna address more next
semester it appears to be a lot about
race they appear to have gone through a
couple syllabi for critical race Theory
classes and just yanked a lot of those
books but there's also books on religion
and like schizophrenia and the prison
system and a lot there's a lot happening
in there that needs more qualitative
analysis but certainly like as you saw
in here the top words appearing are
American African social history race
relations conditions politics prison
discrimination etc yeah yep
yeah there's a lot of reasons yep back
yeah
I looked at the data and came up with
what was a stop word in that dataset so
I just reran it I was like I think it
only took out about five stop words
which are like the and of in etc yeah
but I did it just sort of actually I
didn't just bring in a generic stop word
list I just looked at the actual words
and popularity of the words and pulled
the stop where it's directly from the
data documentation libraries more
thinking or friendly the the sort of
obvious comeback my people then that
sort of sack like that sort of taking a
different continuum you know friendly
continuum you know can documentation be
honest all people how do you choose or
where a cynic yeah so I have two answers
to this the first one is I tried I
actually put in an issue into the
Seabourn documentation and I was like
can you put your acknowledgment of Tidy
data format at the beginning and not at
the end I'm willing to do it I just not
sure like which thing it's coming in
from cuz it was like not obvious it was
not really sure what was happening and
the response was no thank you because
we've thought about it a lot and they
closed the issue so okay sure um but
yeah balancing that tension between like
what is reference and versus instruction
is difficult I think again it's not the
responsibility of open-source maintainer
to like teach people to bar chart is but
at a minimum you could put a sentence of
like here our expectations for this
usage if you're showing a bunch of
examples of people hitting a data frame
like say the data frame should have a
column like this and a column like that
and just say like in natural human words
get your data into this order somehow or
like have a column where all of your
categorical labels live inside of a
single column like simple one sentence
in there just and it's like bullet point
to be totally fine
and so it doesn't have to be a ton what
you're looking for is aiming it like one
of the most minimal prompts required to
like a pro
really halt someone in their tracks and
to say like oh I didn't do that oh I
don't have a CSV oh I have 156 XML files
I guess I need to sort that business out
just acknowledge your required business
rules and you notice I had to be long
but like that's what I would start with
first just like can you come up with
five like expectations before you get
started in this tutorial and if you can
take you'll set further and say like
here's some tutorials for like how to
get there in there here's like or here's
the pandas documentation that like works
really well for this tool or something
like that
but the minimum just say what you want
it depends on sort of where you're at
whether or not you're beginning to
programming or you're beginning to
Python or you're just beginning to
pandas and you already have programming
and Python inside of there so get really
good at googling but don't just get go
to Google and get good at assessing the
results like we talked about this in
like freshman year research right we're
like you type in Civil War into Google
you get some results you have to like
first off look at the URLs coming up
because if it's like data science
tutorials com versus like pandas org
like one of those is gonna be a little
bit more authoritative in there also
look at dates as well especially with
Stack Overflow posts because pandas is
an ever-changing landscape and there's
certain like deprecated cleverness in
the language that still exists so if you
hit a sack or a full page that's like
about usually cautioned about five years
plus old you probably want to try and
look for something a little bit newer
because the language has evolved a
little bit more so look at the source
look at the date when you're looking at
Stack Overflow don't read the title
don't read the user's question go
straight down to the first answer and
only read the code and if the code
doesn't help you move on
right um have trusted people around you
to help out with things and don't be
afraid to ask questions
I learned alone because I stubbornly
refused to ask for help and it was
inefficient and traumatizing and so
you're gonna have to find resources that
speak well to you but keep good notes as
well and remember that it's like a
nonlinear process so especially with
pandas and other tools and frameworks
using something like X mind or like a
mind mapping tool to take notes and
making a little mini reference database
that makes sense to you I think is one
of the best ways to do it
yeah so come here and ask questions keep
a list keep a Google Doc of light or
something on your phone if like
questions to ask the next Python person
you see
and that is we need to take so so we
need to like remind people in tutorials
bad they they need to do a lot of ETL
before they get to that it's fine that
we expect CSVs and data frames that's
not necessarily a bad thing it'd be cool
if you did something else but like it's
fine to have certain expectations and
requirements for a data model for your
tool what's missing though is a coherent
just from many is a coherent discussion
of those expectations for it
so like mat plot libs expectations for
doing visualization versus Seaborn's
expectations for data structure in there
be clear about your expectations I'd
like for this tutorial to use on your
own data you should plan on being able
to load text files into something so
something like that so like take a
moment when you're saying here I'm going
to load this can data I'm going to load
it into this specific kind of structure
and just be clear have a couple
sentences about like expectations about
that and don't just like wham I'm gonna
load tips and we're gonna do a
visualization like you should be at
least a little bit more to books on a
firearm but also as a open-source
package maintaining myself I've been
inspired that I need to do it at least a
little bit better and try to be
inclusive and also the things that we're
leaving on the table or the people that
we're leaving leaving out right so let's
think again Elizabeth for a great talk
[Applause]